uh i want to start by saying how much i
enjoyed your movie
and uh how happy i am you guys have the
time to talk
and um but before we get into the movie
i have a few other kind of questions
um so uh for the actors on this call
what tv series would you love to guest
star on
and gita what tv series would you love
to guest direct
i'll go first i'd love to be in
australia and guess her on the wire
what's that
i hate this show i'm so jealous of this
show
both of you guys what i want a piece
and that's the time that this is when
soph says that she wants to be somewhere
else
oh yeah i would also guest star on the
wilds
no um actually you know what i was
talking about the boys
last night with some friends and it's a
really good show it's dark
i would love to do something like that
like a superhero would be
sick yeah oh um
actually
what i like to do maybe i also like to
guest star on um uh miss marvel
yeah that would be sick um
but invincible you have given me a good
idea though invincible which the
that's an incredible show as well on
prime and i've just binged that
that'd be fun also totally different but
it's reality i've been binging survivor
i don't know if any of you guys have
seen it very
i might be exaggerating but 72 seasons
of survivor
um so i'm i'm joking but there's a lot
did you start at the very beginning
no so i started on season 28 returning
who's a legend apparently because i know
you went on to win it twice
but um yeah i've just been binging a
couple seasons but it's been really fun
we don't have it back home in the uk so
something new and different you know i
love that show
[Music]
there's so much drama real life drama so
much oh my god
the issues i would never want to direct
well i shouldn't say that i wouldn't
want a direct survivor because i
like to be inside and you know not
eating bugs and things like that
i would direct i would love to direct on
russian doll did you guys see russian
doll
yeah love that show i love atlanta i
love insecure
i would love to i mean if i'm just like
wishing for things that's what i would
wish for
i asked this question of a lot of people
you never know someone might see it
you know you really never know
[Laughter]
uh so the next question is and i don't
mean just in the last year i mean
whole life what movie or movies do you
think you've seen the most
sneakers for me i've seen sneakers a
million times
i've seen soul a bunch of times oh yeah
nice
it doesn't feel good film yeah
uh nacho libre it's my go-to
i swear to god i think i can
recite it in my sleep
brilliant every time jack black and
um i think his name is stephen or the
character oh my god
excuse hector their nuances are like
incredible like every little thing that
they do every time i watch it i find
something new
so naturally do you guys have any movie
or tv show props
at home i have i'm like right off i have
the
um yes let me tell you all about my
movie memorabilia i um
i have a stay puft marshmallow man
figure from ghostbusters i have a prop
from
a movie i've been in a really long time
ago i did a movie when i was
17 and i died in it and i was scalped
um did you keep help yeah i kept the
brain
nice piece it was a
it was not it wasn't the best movie um
but yeah it's still cool
kept my brain i'm trying to think
i've got i've got a few bits and bobs
from that place i've done in the past
stolen stuff from there no no you didn't
steal you hypothetically borrowed
i let me yeah exactly i've borrowed and
i will return it
on the cross parts again down the line
um
inevitably and hopefully but uh yeah
yeah that's about it
i'm trying to collect stuff as i go at
the moment but my suitcases are just
filling up and
i'm running out of space so it's gotta
be things oh
from india sweets and spices i have the
her backdrop in her room oh nice that's
a good wait is it the woman
kicking the unicorn the girl kicking the
unicorn yes yeah she gave that to me as
a rap gift
it's a good one it's sweet for each of
you
do you remember what it was early in
your life that got you
interested in wanting to pursue what
you're doing
was it a performance was it a movie like
what was do you remember was there a
spark
early in your life that like oh my god i
want to do that
cameron d is dancing in her underwear
and
um
harley's angels
wow you can do that i want to do that
you know like not that but you know just
she owned her power
she just owned it you know what i mean
like she was dancing in her underwear
and she was just like she looked great
i don't know cool to see it was cool to
see
i feel like i have multiple moments um
i've i was always a writer so i feel
like i
i always wanted to be creative and
express myself but i think for
film i mean i have certain scenes that
have stuck in my head in certain films
that have you know a little close to my
heart
um i think it was really i had written a
short play and the play went up on stage
and um someone else directed it and i
felt like oh that's but i want
i want to direct it like i whatever i
had written i felt like
i wanted to still sort of control how it
was being portrayed
um so i think maybe that was a real
spark that led me to
want to learn how to direct i think that
was probably it i've always loved
attention
and i think like when i was a kid i used
to tell stories and if i felt like
someone was an answer
it wasn't listening i'd like start all
the way at the top and i'd just talk
relentlessly for like five minutes
straight to my mom about the most
mundane thing
so i think it probably started there um
but i i grew up watching bollywood and i
was obsessed with
that whole world and i used to reenact
scenes with my cousins and want to be
shahrukh khan so it probably was that
even though i don't really watch any of
those films anymore uh i get very messed
up
and i look back at them you know so uh
yeah probably that
i was probably just very self-obsessed
as a child
at least he's aware you know
probably probably but yeah uh jumping
into why i actually get to talk to you
guys today
um everyone watching this no one will
have seen the movie yet
i hate asking like the generic thing but
can you describe
the movie to people that aren't familiar
with it so india sweets and spices is
the story of alia played by sophia ali
who's a college kid who comes home
between her freshman and sophomore year
um and thinks it's gonna be a really
boring summer her parents are nagging
her she's just back in this community
um and she ends up finding out all these
secrets about her family
and those secrets sort of turn her world
upside down and they galvanize her to
make a big change in her world and then
also
for her parents to make a big change in
their world so sort of a coming of age
for her but also for her parents for her
mom specifically
what was it about the script and story
that immediately pulled you in and said
i want to be a part of this
and i was touched on this uh when we
were talking the other day
though it was basically just how um
relatable this story is from for me from
hearing
varun side of the story through the eyes
of my my parents and and
um first of all like the story of my dad
coming to the uk when he was
around that age um and younger than i am
now
and um just trying to assimilate
and i feel like me then being born
as a second generation uh indian in the
uk
i've seen my parents working so hard my
whole life
and just kind of appreciating that and
and seeing that you know varun's also
in that headspace of his parents are
working really hard
as the any i mean any child of an
immigrant
sees their parents struggle and um work
hard to try and
provide a better life so that was
something which kind of struck a chord
with me
uh definitely and it was mostly also
just the fact that
this is such a beautiful script with an
amazing amazing
um like writer which is our director
and um it's female-led and i was able to
play a part which
helps kind of aid that story in a small
way but one which is
really important i think and uh really
exciting to help what
what gita was just describing the movies
about to help kind of um
help earlier navigate
that that difficulty that she's
processing as she's um
figuring out what's going on what's
going on at home and stuff like that and
whilst also navigating his own
um you know they they really help each
other and i thought it was a really
interesting dynamic
i guess just to piggyback off of what he
said because i you know
agree with everything obviously i don't
relate to it all because i'm not from
the uk
but um uh yeah
um also so stoked just to
see it like cross my path i was like
whoa
oh my god what this is happening
like now people are going to watch this
you're saying that like people want to
see this kind of stuff that's sick
you know that was the first time that
would that had even
crossed my mind you know like oh okay
well yeah yeah here we are meaning like
that yeah the all south asian cast and
that kind of thing yeah you know i'm not
like gonna be playing a stereotype or
like the best friend my whole career
that's not you know
one of the things that i like is when
i'm sort of a curtain is removed
to another um culture to another group
of people that i'm not
exposed to on an everyday basis i love
that and i feel like this film pulls the
curtain back on this
i guess you could argue typical indian
american family
you know and what's going on and can you
sort of talk about that aspect that
you know you are pulling that curtain
back yeah i think it is
certainly that um you know i grew up in
a um
homogenous society uh but there were
indians in our community and the indians
would all get together and be part of
these dinner parties and
for us it was just that's just how we
lived it didn't feel like there was
two different worlds necessarily one or
the other um
but it was very natural for us and i
think that's
important for me in this film is to say
that this is not some other community
this is not some it's very
we're integrated into american life this
is just what
we do on the weekends we go and we eat
our food and we wear our outfits you
know and that sort of thing but it is
i grew up as an indian american i grew
up here um
and so it is it is sort of pulling back
the curtain on
the traditions maybe and um
the sort of uh just this community that
comes together
um that maybe you don't see all the time
in mainstream media that being said i
feel like the story is very universal
this is a small town
it's a small town that just happens to
be full of indians in the midst of
america
and i think that the three of us are
actually really a solid good example of
what she just described
here i am in australia you know
totally indian yes in australia
i would imagine that um obviously you
had to make this film
on a budget you had a finite amount of
days this is not some big marvel movie
uh can you sort of talk about the
challenges of trying to bring this to
life
obviously on a budget yes um
well the film does take place over the
course of several
glittering glamorous dinner parties um
and so we had to really use our budget
wisely to put
as much money as we could on screen um
so
you know just we had a wonderful really
deep bench of actors
people brought their own outfits at
times you know um
people were very very uh i think it's
the same as what sophia and rich were
saying people were very excited to be
part of this film
because it's an all south asian cast
almost all there's like maybe one or two
non-south asian characters in the whole
film and so people were really willing
to to join in and to
bring their own resources you know we
borrowed a car from our i think from our
ac
um that features in one of the scenes
you know everyone was just really
willing to pitch in
um and i think that helped a lot because
we did have a very finite amount of time
and a finite amount of dollars so yeah
it was actually really inspirational to
see
a lot on set you know you could tell
that
people were just there because they
believed in it and they wanted to be
there
which is really really freaking cool
you know they're not like i need
overtime you know
just i don't know attitude oh sorry oh
no i was gonna i was about to say the
same thing but it was my first time on
on a
on a movie set ever so for me like i
feel really lucky that that was the
first experience i got to have because
um like ever you know just to reiterate
there was so much passion behind it and
everyone was so
so thrilled and um like honored to be
there
that it really like was just this
amazing bubble i didn't want i didn't
want it to pop you know
it it felt like it was too quick so
yeah it was it was just a joy to be
there i'm always curious about editing
because it's the final rewrite and you
really never know what you have until
you step in the editing room
so can you sort of talk about you get in
the editing room you have your footage
are you freaking out are you like um
i feel like i i love working with an
amazing editor and we had amazing
editors on this project because i'm
so my eyes are so tired at that point so
i don't know
i feel like i walk in going like i don't
know if we got it i honestly don't know
it's a sea of footage to me it's a sea
of scenes
um and then coming back to it and seeing
me in even the assembly and seeing
something that's like three to four
hours whatever it is i'm like oh
that feels like a relief to me um once
we finish shooting i feel like you know
what i've seen in the monitor what i've
seen on daily
is is wonderful but then having someone
else come in and say oh
and helping me rewrite the story a
little bit and take pieces that i
wouldn't have thought of that fit in
certain i mean i love i love that
collaboration um
so i i i don't ever feel like yes it's
we nailed it i never feel like that i'm
all just like where am i
at the end of a movie and then coming
into the edit room is very
comforting actually to see all of it
laid out and then i you know knowing
what you have i think really helps
i've spoken to a lot of actors and some
actors they cannot watch themselves
it makes them crazy and other actors
love to dissect their performance and
then rip it apart
so for the two of you what was it like
for you guys watching this film
could you watch it can you watch
yourself um
i'm not particularly self-conscious
conscious um
sorry uh now i am
um so i mean i don't like i don't
analyze myself too much but i also
have a hard time seeing it like that's
me you know i don't know it's it's um
it's like there's a difference watching
a movie you're
invested in this story and you know you
you're wondering what's going to happen
but when i'm watching myself there's
like none of that mystery so it's not
like
entertaining for me you know i just feel
like i'm watching myself do something
that i did
you're like i'm so self-critical which
is like
i mean i'm still so new to this whole
thing i say that it's
just been a minute but i feel like i'm
new to it you know i haven't seen myself
in a lot of stuff and this is one of
the things which i've seen myself you
know when i did get to watch it
um and for me like
i was nervous but i loved watching the
film because i was just thinking back to
oh this day was so fun because i
remember doing all of this
you know it wasn't like oh i should have
done this differently or
um i hate the way i did that or oh
actually i really like what i did here
it's just like
oh that was a sick day and we all had
fun and i remember like
us talking about this afterwards and the
creative process
i definitely don't grow as an actor from
watching myself
i grow more on set i feel like in
exploring
avenues that way in in real time rather
than
criticizing myself afterwards yeah
you're such a good you're
if i can just jump in you're so great on
set both of you are of course you're
amazing actors so if he has a real um
loose this isn't the right word but
you're very um in the moment
you're very spontaneous which i think is
it's great it helps a lot on set
yeah there's some improv and stuff that
you've done that has made it into the
film which is exciting so
it's i've been doing these like okay
this is something i need to work on now
so
every project is sort of like i'm going
to hammer that down but i'm trying to be
better at the technical side of it you
know like
understanding where the shots are and
playing towards that
and not so much being like seeing even
just how that translates and like what
it looks like
am i going to look worse or better i
don't know you know
it's a mystery and i'm excited one of
the things i enjoyed oh
something like this is like the big
group scenes it's what it pulls you in
and you sort of like you know it
explores that area and with all the
different characters
so i'm curious if you could all talk
about filming those big group scenes
and now is the time to tell me who
ruined the most things
definitely me
what did you do richard probably
i was like i was stumbling in like this
no i hope not um those
group scenes for me were like so much
fun because
like we sleep going back to what we're
saying before everyone was just so
excited to be there
and we had like a whole bunch of really
great supporting
um background artists who were like
just elated and it just made the
environment amazing was it always going
to be called
india's sweet sweets and spices no the
original title was dinner with friends
which is
not a great title because there's our
you know there's a pulitzer
prize-winning
play called dinner with friends they
made a movie out of it also called
dinner with friends
um so no it was not always called that
so the
the name came a little bit later i could
sort of see
the importance of putting india in the
title but i could also see
why you wouldn't put it was there did
you feel like was there a lot of debate
on that there was some debate um i will
say i
have generally shied away from adding
india to a title
because it happens to star indian people
i feel like we don't always need to put
the ethnicity front and center
and also the sweets and spices thing um
you know it comes from this it's an
homage to
a lot of indian stores that we all grew
up with from you know jersey to wherever
all over the country there are india
sweets and spices um
or some you know variation of that name
um for me i did i feel like there are
certain signifiers that always turn up
in movies about indians there's mango
this or you know
wedding that um so i do try to avoid
that and that's why i didn't title it
you know something
pointing to the ethnicity initially that
being said a lot of this
a lot of the crucial scenes in this film
take place at the grocery store
um so it seemed to make sense when we
were trying to brainstorm okay what
could be alternate titles it seemed to
make sense
that the story that they were portraying
in the film
um became more front and center i
definitely curious if you guys can
just touch on real quick uh what it
means to be premiering at tribeca
in the film festival it's a dream come
true and especially after the crazy year
we've had
with covid and all that of course um
being at the first in-person
film festival in the states is huge and
the fact that i get to be here in new
york is
huge so it's really meaningful to me
it's been a long journey
so i'm glad to be here are you guys both
in new york right now
no that sound gutted i can't be there
but it means so
much that it's you're not gonna be there
i know i'm filming
but uh it's it's amazing it's so cool
that you know people get to have this
experience
of our movie together in the cinema um
because it's it's really something which
i think people would love to
to share this experience you know i
think it would be really great for them
to be able to do that
and what an amazing festival to be a
part of i mean it's a privilege
yeah i wish i could be there but yeah
i'm really excited for everyone
it means a lot it really does i'm i wish
that i could be there more than anything
um also in the name of progress
you know it's great it's it's so cool
it just speaks volumes you know that
people want to see this that that
tribeca would be excited about it you
know
i want to see everything with a crowd it
makes every movie better yeah
just does for sure you know for sure uh
well unless you have a terrible audience
before i run into time with you guys uh
because i can see the clock um i
definitely have to ask uh uh
sophia i of course have to ask you how
has it been going
on wild season two and for fans of the
series what can you say
oh man what can i say i don't even know
what i can say
um but it's been so amazing there's boys
now um there's a boys island so now
we've introduced eight
men into the cast and they're actually
all phenomenal phenomenal actors and
people um they're like it's just
most perfect additions i'm so excited
for people to watch them and fall in
love with them just as much as they did
the women and also the girls you know
are on their own venture
i have to ask you uh about miss marvel
just because that is uh really
[ __ ] cool sorry for the language um
yeah so talk talk a little bit about uh
what was it like making that series
and what fans can look forward to ah
um it's just been an absolute
dream of mine and i'm still kind of
pinching myself
the it's happened um and
you know you know how the marvel thing
goes i mean anyone who's a fan of it
will love
will love to see i hope and i hope the
fans enjoy our show
um it's it's just amazing to be a part
of the mcu and
to work with the amazing amazing people
that i've got to
uh that i've looked up to for so long
and um
like our creators and stuff so it's just
it's been it's been really cool it's
been really really cool
and i can't wait for it to be out there
yeah something something that i'm
actually and i'll just
talk about this but like gita obviously
uh
it's great when your actors are also in
these other big
projects because it does help get people
to
see a movie like this which is not a
marvel movie or being pushed hardcore on
amazon
like it brings a lot of you know it
shines a light on this can you sort of
you know
i guess if you guys could hope you could
talk about that a little bit yeah no
that's huge you're absolutely right
because we're such you know we're an
indie film and we're
like all south asian cast again you know
it's very hard
to break through when there are big
marvel movies and big summer movies just
movies in general we're on a much
smaller scale than most of these films
um and so you know soph and rich are
such they're
amazing people and they're amazing
actors so it's amazing
amazing it's just always amazing
everything's amazing
um to see them you know blossom in these
new roles as well i feel like
it's you know i'm very cheesy and i'm
also a mother so i'm just like oh
look at these guys go out to the world
and they didn't need
anything from me of course because
they're just amazing on their own
amazing again i can't think of another
word right now
um but it does you're absolutely right
it helps bring attention to our film
because they are
um their talents are being noticed um in
bigger and bigger arenas and that's
fantastic
it's fantastic for our film i know that
we wouldn't be in this position i'm
speaking on your wealth as well
sorry to have said we but i'm you know
where it's true we wouldn't be in this
position without without guitar
honestly she's the most important person
on the planet
and she really is like a mother to me
it's it's just every project is
different and
um hopefully each one of them hopefully
people want to watch miss marvel because
they've seen me in the suites you know
and they know i'm part of that
so i think it's it's a two-way street
and it's just it's an honor to be
working in the industry
i have to ask you are you writing
anything or what's your next thing yes
i am currently writing something for a
studio um which i also hope to direct
um and then i'm also writing my own
specs i'm always writing
a million projects at once so i'm
writing my own specs again hopefully
with the eye
on directing those as well and then i'm
developing some tv i've got um
two tv shows that are in development
right now so we'll see what happens
things are moving you know stuff on the
stove cooking
direct an episode of the ones yeah i
mean i'll just fly over
do you want to you should you should
yeah i'll let's put that out there let's
put it out to the world
the wild's amazing